let's talk about keeping the face
celebrating births and marriages
mourning the dead coming together to
mark the holidays
they've all been derailed sacred sites
and places of worship have been closed
tsilya abrasive absolutely Tiffany but a
monster Haram booze no big festivals no
shared meals no proper funerals whether
you're religious or not so how are
people coping how do we maintain our
spiritual and cultural practices under
lockdown and what can we all do to stay
strong
[Music]
some of us choose to navigate through
life on our own but the vast majority of
people turn to religion for spiritual
sustenance direction and community
especially when times are hard and this
pandemic is one of those times over 85
percent of the world's population
considers religion very important in
their lives and so when they cannot
gather as a result of the social
restrictions of kovat 19 it feels like
an incredible loss governments around
the world have bound religious and
spiritual gatherings to contain the
pandemic and with good reason probably
the most notorious example of what
they're trying to avoid is the story of
patient 31 in early february a woman in
south korea developed a fever and went
to hospital she was tested for code 19
but before her results came back she
attended at least four church services
she even went for a buffet lunch
by the start of March more than 4,000
people were infected 60% of them were
from her church easy to see how just one
person can become a super spreader case
okay so and I'm not a mother I'm a heya
hanun coup de la bruja pretty cool young
to tango you all sent a John Doe 2010
you can go guru dip welcome Kyle it's
okay so I gave it a series of common
wrong
April is a big month for religious
holidays but this year things had to
change
Jews who would normally share meals and
prayers for Passover were forced to
congregate online I'm here to welcome
all of you to our zoom Pesach instead of
celebrating Mass before tens of
thousands of worshippers in st. Peter's
Square
Pope Francis live streamed his Palm
Sunday sermon seeks usually hold the
festival vaisakhi this year they did it
at a safe distance
there were other celebrations too like
Orthodox Easter
and Hindu festival called Rama Navami
and now Ramadan is a month of fasting
considered holy by 2 billion Muslims
around the world people won't gather
together for breaking the fast to pray
in the evenings and they won't gather
together when it comes to me either
where people come together celebrate the
end of it's gonna be a little more
different than usual but I think the
faithful around the world no matter what
their religion are having to adjust and
congregations are getting creative
[Music]
families are re-enacting rituals at home
many are taking advantage of technology
or tuning into more traditional channels
every Sunday now if you want to attend
the mass you can just turn on your TV
and that's also good that said not
everyone has found it easy to adapt my
parents they seem to be having a little
bit of a hard time one of the ways for
them to cope with it you know it's is
their faith and just putting everything
in God's hands but right now you know
like that's penis trouble others just
can't afford the tech those groups that
are least resource may also be the
groups that most need religion and it
goes beyond the spiritual some people
rely on their religious community to
make sure they get enough to eat they
might provide economic benefit for
people and they of course provide
emotional and psychological support and
there's probably no more difficult time
than losing someone the pandemic has
forced restrictions on funerals and
burials that defy our universal rituals
of saying goodbye
[Music]
some cultures are adapting traditional
ceremonies this farewell to a prominent
Maori leader was broadcast on national
television in New Zealand but for a lot
of people saying goodbye from a distance
or online just isn't enough the family
all being together with her it would
have helped us grieve together for a
moment as well which helps you also
acknowledge the enormity of what's
happened it still feels like I'm gonna
have to wake up tomorrow and ring people
and tell them I got it wrong and that
she's still alive
Espo's Picard okay legionary de la verga
mo reporting new pays devolve rainbow
pasta Manali salute our Luba nadir lo
accompany our impulses to semplice
[Music]
all of this put spiritual and religious
leaders in a tough spot many want to
provide comfort to their followers but
they're also obliged to stop them from
coming together and that goes against
centuries of religious practices
historically I can't imagine any Imam
any leader of Hamas and ever having a
situation where they have to close the
doors of the mosque supposed to be
sanctuary at times of difficulty the
vast majority of religious leaders and
scholars around the world are leading by
example but some are breaking the rules
remember the story about patient 31 some
local leaders have called for shin chon
G's elders to be investigated for
possible homicide several church leaders
are accused of hiding the identities of
their followers from South Korean
officials trying to track down cases of
Kovach 19
[Applause]
other religious communities have ignored
lockdowns to large weddings by Hasidic
Jews went ahead in New York some Muslims
and Malaysia kept going to Friday
prayers Mecca churches and US states
like Florida and Louisiana were still
packed blessed and bless them for a holy
boldness and it's caused a backlash for
example an Islamic group in India held
an event against police orders that led
to a surge in anti-muslim violence it's
a trying time for a lot of people none
of us have ever lived through anything
like this before
closing more public spaces forcibly
separated from loved ones around a
hundred thousand people have died world
powers that are armed for the club's
biggest Wars are now fighting for basic
protective gear
lockdowns are already taking a toll on
our spiritual and mental well-being
everybody is having not a fear panic
anxiety
we shouldn't under emphasize the
collateral impact that Kovach 19 social
restrictions will have on our mental
health and on our psyche so in absence
of a physical connection people are
coping the best they can utilize
technology because getting together and
meeting is really important especially
in times like these yeah we enormous it
isn't difficult government and the front
I miss jalwa
we can bring this work it's not really
from outside it's from here what you
feel here if just keep believing keep
praying for the health workers to those
who seek and for yourselves who are
sitting at home say it's in difficult
times like this that people turn to
their faith and to each other for
support it shows just how precious our
sense of community
really
we don't know when we'll be back on the
start here set but not to worry we're
still going to be bringing you more
episodes any way we can in the meantime
our website aljazeera.com has all the
latest on the corona virus pandemic I'll
see you next week
[Music]